if X is a whole number what other sets
does X belong to and we saw a couple of
videos ago that I mentioned that the
notion of the set of whole numbers is a
little bit ambiguous sometimes whole
number means non-negative integers so
sometimes it means non-negative integers
and sometimes it means all integers but
in this context and I actually looked at
what the writers of this question are
looking for and the standards that they
care about so from their point of view
when they refer to whole numbers they're
referring to non-negative integers so
they're referring to 0 1 2 3 so on and
so forth and I also look at what they
refer to and remember this is just
according to the writers of this
question this isn't according to how
everyone views these things but they
view as not they view natural numbers
they view natural numbers as just the
positive numbers as just the positive
numbers I told you two videos ago that
some people view natural numbers as just
the positive but some people include
zero as a natural number but in this
context it's just the positive integers
I shouldn't have said positive numbers I
should have said positive integers it
obviously doesn't include the numbers in
between the integers so naturally the
numbers in this context you'll see other
contexts where this would be described
as natural in this context and natural
numbers are 1 2 3 4 so on and so forth
and of course there's no ambiguity about
what integers are everyone agrees on
that integers are we could just you know
it's you could go arbitrarily negative
and there's negative 3 negative 2
negative 1 0 1 2 3 and you can just keep
going in the positive direction so if X
is a whole number when they say whole
numbers they mean it is non-negative
what other sets does X belong to well if
it's a whole number it's any one of
these numbers and all of these numbers
are also integers right the whole set of
whole numbers by by the convention
they're using is this set right here it
is a sub set of integers it is a sub set
of integers so we know that X is also an
integer X X is also a member of
integers that means a member a member of
a set X is also a member of integers but
it will not be a member of natural
numbers or at least the way that they've
defined it because a whole number a
whole number 0 X could be 0 0 is
considered a whole number but if X were
0 it would not be a member of the
natural numbers so we can't say it's
natural all we can say is is that it's
definitely integers
it's definitely rational because any
whole number you can just divide it by 1
and represent it as a fraction so X is a
member of rationals and of course it's
also a member of the real which is the
broadest set that we know of